foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing whether nagini
Voldemort's faithful pet snake turned
Hawk Crux would have turned evil if the
dark lord hadn't harbored a piece of his
splintered Soul inside of her let's sink
our teeth into this one shall we all
right so most of you will know nikini
from the original Harry Potter novels
and films she was an enormous snake and
an unquestionably loyal servant of Lord
Voldemort who he often kept close at
hand to help him carry out his dirty
work you know eating the odd witch or
wizard attacking members of the Order of
the Phoenix and the likes of that of
course as we find out in the final
installment of the series nagini is also
one of Voldemort's seven horcruxes which
is likely another reason he kept her
nearby at all times that was why
according to Albus Dumbledore at least
anyway being that Voldemort born Tom
marvala Riddle was a descendant of
Salazar Slytherin he possessed the
ability to speak parcel tongue an
extremely rare language that but plainly
meant that he could talk to snakes his
ability to communicate with nagini
further shows why they would have had a
close Bond and perhaps explains
Voldemort's reasoning behind making the
guinea horcrux in the first place here
was a creature that he could speak to
but who wouldn't betray his confidence
in a way a human could but wouldn't it
be a bit dicey to literally put your
life in the hands the scales of a snake
well here's where nagini's backstory
gets interesting she actually used to be
a woman as JK Rowling has continued to
expand the Harry Potter Universe since
the release of the Deathly Hallows in
2007 we have learned more and more about
characters who weren't given the most
substantial backstories in the original
series nagini is one of those characters
her origin story was at last revealed to
the Fantastic Beasts movie franchise the
prequel film series 2 Harry Potter in
the second movie installment Fantastic
Beasts the crimes of Grindelwald we
discovered that bikini not always been a
snake she was in fact at one time a
human Woman as a woman she was a
maledictus meaning she was born with a
blood curse that at first allowed her to
transform back and forth between a human
and a snake sadly as with all
maledictuses she eventually lost the
ability to control her Transformations
and the Affliction ultimately trapped
her in the form of a serpent this
beastial version of nagini was of course
the only one we used to know the
unusually intelligent and malevolent pet
Serpent of Lord Voldemort but with the
telling of the Guinea's origin story we
are shown the type of woman she was
before she became Voldemort's loyal pets
and it wouldn't be shocked if many of
you like myself were quite surprised to
find that the guinea was not completely
terrible as a human in fact it would
seem that she was actually quite moral
and good let me explain in Fantastic
Beasts the crimes of Grindelwald we are
introduced to nagini through Credence a
wayward Wizard and obscurial who was in
search of Clues to his past greentz
meets nagini after he joins a traveling
Wizarding Circus the circus arcanus and
the two form a close friendship we
witness nagini be kind and compassionate
towards Credence and she becomes
concerned when he shows interest in
joining the powerful dark wizard Gellert
Grindelwald ultimately despite caring
for Credence the guinea chooses to help
the likes of newt's commander and Albus
Dumbledore in their efforts to defeat
Grindelwald a far cry from where she
ends up with the Wizarding world's next
Great Dark Lord Voldemort which brings
us to the question if nagini was once a
good and kind woman how and when did she
turn so evil was it in fact when
Voldemort turned her into his horcrux in
all honesty I rather think not here's
why if being made into a horcrux had the
ability to turn the vessel of the
horcrux into an evil creature or being
wouldn't Harry Potter become undeniably
evil himself when Voldemort
unintentionally turned him into one as a
baby yes right but of course course we
know that didn't happen even if Harry
wasn't a full-on horcrux in fact we
didn't even know that Harry was a
horcrux until the very end of the final
installment of the series it was a good
wizard he was a moral person who is
maybe a little stubborn and misguided at
times but evil Harry never so then why
did nagini turn so evil if not from
being made into the Dark Lord's Hawk
racks I think the answer to that is not
a simple one as a maledictus at first
nagini had the ability to go back and
forth between her two forms that if a
woman that of a snake I wouldn't be
surprised if she had found it quite
fascinating to start with she may have
even enjoyed it at one time or another
but once she permanently became a snake
can you imagine how trapped and isolated
she would have felt knowing that she
would never be able to interact with the
world as a human ever again she had no
one to talk to no one to pass a time
with to be perfectly honest it would be
enough to make anyone go mad really
don't you think but then again bad
redness does not necessarily equate to
being evil Q Lord Voldemort okay so how
exactly did nagini and Voldemort meet
her a maladictus serpent and he a
phantom-like version of himself due to
his failed attempt to murder an
infantary well the theory goes that deep
in the forest of Albania nagini met the
shadowy remains of the dark lord it was
here that he was rumored to have
befriended many of the animals that he
came across in the woods which of course
included nagini and so finally she had
found someone or something with whom she
could communicate Voldemort who could
speak to her in parcel tongue was also
able to inhabit her body it's not that
far-fetched to think that an
impenetrable Bond would have formed
especially on nagini's behalf and so
nagini having been driven a little bit
mad due to her isolation from humanity
and living in the woods as a beast
likely would have been all too open to
well whatever her new best mate
Voldemort suggested especially if it
included her sticking with him when he
left the forest of Albania this would
have been a very unique maybe even once
in a lifetime opportunity for nagini an
opportunity for her to rejoin the
Wizarding World in a way she probably
hadn't thought possible before meeting
Voldemort after all parcel tongue was an
incredibly rare language and yet it was
this wizard who could understand and
talk to her I can only imagine this
would have come as an intense relief for
nikini from there well we know the rest
nagini became Voldemort's most loyal pet
it was nagini who helped him regain his
strength while in his shadow form her
Venom was a key part of the potion that
enabled him to return to a temporary
body and then nagini herself was made
into a horcrux further helping him
return to power when Voldemort took the
life of Bertha jawkins after that they
were rarely separated she witnessed him
before murder after murder and she
killed on his behalf and was constantly
all of this clearly shows that nagini
most certainly did turn evil but I
believe she did so long before becoming
one of Voldemort's horcruxes and so in
my opinion Nikki still would have become
evil even if she hadn't been made into a
horcrux she may have even turned evil
without having met this particular dark
lord after all maledictus has lost the
ability to think like a human as time
went on so it's possible that she may
have become more and more wicked as she
lived life permanently as a snake
but since it's not inevitable for
maledictus to become evil despite the
Affliction coming from a blood curse I
think that the main reason nagini turned
evil was her relationship with Voldemort
rather than any form of magic but curse
horcrux or otherwise in her desperation
to connect with the being more
intelligent than the Woodland creatures
she lived amongst in the forest of
Albania she was willing to be whatever
the dark lord needed her to be and that
just so happened to be an evil serpent
willing to do his bidding
which brings us to the end of this video
what do you guys think do you agree that
it was nagini's relationship with
Voldemort that turned her evil or do you
think she was already poised and ready
to be evil on her own when he met her or
was it something else entirely let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
dinner nagini
[Music]